we question all of our beliefs except
for those that we truly believe and
those we never think to question why
should we process a traumatic event what
does that mean so let's just say
something bad happens in another culture
that might not be bad it's trauma in
this culture it's not trauma in this
culture so if the circumstance is the
same why was it traumatic circumstances
weren't the same why not because the
culture the facts were the same if it's
traumatic in one instance and not
traumatic in another then it means that
we can basically change the cultural
narrative that we're ascribing to our
context and make it not traumatic well
let's say like the passing of a parent
we have a narrative that says if I don't
mourn it means I didn't care about them
that's a statement of belief why does my
mourning have any indication of how much
I cared they're non-correlates we have
so many of these belief statements that
quote Society or things that we inherit
but we just choose to say that this is
how life is when someone's like I was
traumatized it's like were you or do you
just choose to label this trauma and
then now you've up the rest of
your life because you call it trauma
when 200 years ago it was life we just
choose to create meaning around things